this video will teach you how to use
your crutches please watch the entire
video before using your crutches
crutches help you move around without
having to put weight on your injured
foot or leg if you have had an injury -
or an operation on your foot or leg you
may need to use crutches we'll be
talking about certain parts of crutches
in this video the top part of the crutch
is called a crutch pad the handle in the
middle is called a hand grip the rubber
bottom that touches the floor is called
the crutch tip before you use crutches
you will need to make sure they fit your
body correctly step 1 put one crutch
under each arm at the sides of your body
while you're standing step 2
relax your shoulders and let your arms
hang down over the crutches the crutch
pads should not touch your armpits step
3 check the amount of space between your
armpits and the crutch pads there should
be 2 inches or 5 centimeters of space
between them this is about two or three
finger widths this space helps keep the
crutch pads from putting pressure on
nerves and blood vessels in your armpits
pressure on these nerves and blood
vessels may cause arm tingling and
weakness if the crutches are not the
right height you can adjust them check
the instructions that came with your
crutches or contact your health care
provider if you're not sure how to do
this
step four check the height of the crutch
hand grips your wrists should be at the
same level as the hand grips if the hand
grips are not the right height you can
adjust them check the instructions that
came with your crutches or contact your
healthcare provider if you're not sure
how to do this next you'll learn how to
stand with crutches
step one while standing on your
uninjured leg hold one hand grip in each
hand step two squeeze the crutch pads
between the sides of your chest and
upper arms do not rest your arm pits on
the crutch pads to support your weight
you will support your weight on the hand
grips step three spread the crutch tips
apart and put them slightly in front of
you on the floor this is called a tripod
or three-point stance now you'll learn
how to walk with crutches be sure to
look where you're walking don't just
look down at your feet also be aware
that when you walk you will need extra
room on either side of your body for
your crutches step 1 while standing with
the crutches move the crutch tips one
step in front of you step 2
now put your weight onto the handgrips
of your crutches then swing your injured
leg forward
step3 take a step with your uninjured
leg make sure to land level with or just
ahead of your crutches step 4
move your crutch tips forward a bit to
balance your weight repeat the steps to
keep walking sometimes your surgeon may
allow you to put weight on your surgical
leg when walking with crutches you may
be instructed to touch only your toe to
the ground for balance but not put any
weight on it put half of the weight that
you normally do when you walk put as
much weight on your surgical leg as you
can tolerate or not put any weight on
your leg when walking with crutches be
sure to follow your surgeon's
instructions about if and how much
weight to put on your surgical leg when
walking with crutches next you'll learn
how to sit down with crutches
step one stand next to or in front of
the chair
step two move both crutches from under
your arms to your injured side hold them
by the hand grips with that hand
step three grab the chairs armrests or
seat with your other arm step 4
extend your injured leg in front of you
and lower yourself into the seat
and here's how to stand up with crutches
step 1 while seated extend your injured
leg in front of you step 2
move both crutches to you're injured
side hold them by the hand grips with
that hand step 3 put your other hand on
the chair seat or armrests step 4 while
supporting your weight on the chair and
crutches scoot your body to the edge of
the seat and then push yourself up to a
standing position on your uninjured leg
step 5 put one crutch under each arm so
that you are now in a tripod stance now
you'll learn how to use crutches to
climb stairs that have a handrail step 1
begin as close to the stairs as possible
it does not matter which side the
railing is on or which leg is injured
step 2 move the crutch nearest the
railing to the opposite arm hold both
crutches by the hand grips with that
hand step 3 grab the railing with your
free hand lean your weight on the
railing and the hand grips of your
crutches step 4
lift your uninjured leg onto the next
stair step step 5 pull your crutches up
with you on to the stair step repeat
this process for each stair step
you may also need to climb stairs that
don't have a handrail step 1 begin as
close to the stairs as possible keep one
crutch under each arm lean your weight
on the handgrips of your crutches step
two use your uninjured leg to step or
hop up onto the next stair step step 3
pull your crutches up with you on to the
step repeat this process for each stair
step
here's how to go downstairs with a
handrail step one begin as close to the
stairs as possible it does not matter
which side the railing is on or which
leg is injured
step 2 move the crutch nearest the
railing to the opposite arm hold both
crutches by the hand grips with that
hand step 3
grab the railing with your free arm step
4 place your crutches together onto the
step below be sure to place your
crutches in the middle of the stair to
help you balance your weight step 5
move your injured leg forward slightly
lean your weight on the railing and the
handgrips of your crutches step 6
using your uninjured leg step down onto
the next stair step repeat this process
for each stair step
and now here's how to go downstairs
without a handrail step one begin as
close to the stairs as possible keep one
crutch under each arm
step two lean forward and place your
crutches in the middle of the step below
you lean your weight on the handgrips of
your crutches step three
move your injured leg forward slightly
step four with your uninjured leg step
down on to the next stair step repeat
this process for each stair step
now you know how to stand sit down get
up from a chair walk and go up and down
stairs with crutches remember to take it
slow at first give yourself time to get
used to crutches support your weight on
the handgrips not the crutch pads and
ask for help when you need it
you